if you know that you live on cheap and  this is a big one if you know it doesn't  cost you much to live  your risk tolerance goes up because you  don't have other [ __ ] to worry about  real cost of the [ __ ] that you can't  afford or shouldn't be affording right  now is that you're paying for the car  but you're sacrificing your dreams you  become less dangerous  because it's very hard to fight someone  who has nothing to lose  and it's very hard to find someone  who can live on nothing  if we had to pick between living on ten  thousand dollars a month and making ten  thousand dollars a month or living on  fifteen hundred dollars a month and then  spending the spread if you spend five  thousand dollars a month three thousand  dollars a month two thousand dollars a  month on your education so that you can  increase your earning capacity  it's hard to be stopped